[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de papus
le vôtre aux échos notez bien sur vos
droits
ouaddar attention ils ont manqué
[Musique]
les nouveaux locataires ils sont en
retard ça commence bien se sont fait
livrer leurs meubles des meubles st je
ne demande la tête qu'ils ont c'est pas
ta plus apte la peluche quel nom et puis
ils viennent taxi en plus quatre
personnes dont un petit bonjour bonjour
je m'appelle pas de clous voici
mademoiselle pas d'accord et patata
bonjour monsieur et pat asus seulement
partager j'avais compris avez-vous bon
caractère
aubry je pense ya bien pâte asus qu'ils
croient pas ta joue moi je vais pas bon
caractère et j'ai horreur du bruit
autant vous prévenir tout de suite
comment la maison monsieur croignon je
m'appelle e bourgault dépêche-toi pas
tabou
si je les parts de fournoux pas de dîner
voilà voilà
il m'a pas laissé le lien deux coups de
marteau et elle est à toi
[Musique]
ouais temps
en
et
on
non
printemps
[Musique]
m
souvenez vous de ce que je vous ai dit
je ne vais pas d'où il me faut bien
qu'on emmène à genoux sur ronchon vous
est imminent bon d'accord pour
aujourd'hui mais pas de bruit un prêt ne
leur en a pas alors comment peut être
vivre sans heurts je vais vous prêter un
réveil n'a pas leurs commandes ce vieux
bonhomme
moi je n'ai même pas il m'a pas en
laisse sonnant mormons et tâchons de
faire moins de bruit
nous avons dû déménager à cause de ça
attention votre maman
dépêchez vous
pour moi
c'est ce matin votre réveil o o
[Musique]
je crois que maintenant on peut y aller
c'est tout
ta maman
j'attache à ça
[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de pâte
à puce le foot robeco monte bien sûr
vaudois mois dans votre attention
il manque
[Musique]